the movie starts in a busy town center
where everyone's going about their daily
lives the atmosphere seems to be a
mixture of calmness and Tranquility
indicating that the city is free from
the disease that is crime suddenly
hundreds of unidentified flying objects
come tearing through the sky and start
indiscriminately shooting innocent
civilians a man named Peter watches it
transpire in horror from a building
until the flying machines fire a missile
towards him right then Peter wakes up in
a cold sweat next to his wife Alice it
turns out Peter has been experiencing
recurring nightmares in his dreams he
and everyone he knows suffer through
violent alien invasion-like
confrontations with an unknown enemy
Alice has advised her husband many times
to consult a psychiatrist but he always
ignores her mentioning that it'll pass
this is strained the couple's
relationship and now they mostly just
try to ignore each other this must be
what it's like to be married to Tom
Delong Alice and Peter have two
daughters named Hannah and Lucy who are
also worried about him but Peter always
claims that he will eventually figure
out every everything himself the next
day it becomes clear that the
environment at Peter's home is quite
tense because of his recurrent
nightmares therefore to lighten
everyone's mood before leaving for work
Peter promises to take his family to the
pier later that day much to little
Lucy's excitement he also promises to
host a party the next day to celebrate
Alice's promotion at work the strange
thing about the city is that all the
children are always at home because
there are no schools here and education
is non-existent moreover everyone seems
to be too distant from one another
although there are interactions they
seem to be very cold and ingenuine later
at work Peter again has strange Visions
causing one of his equipment to crash as
he snaps out of his dream and tries to
fix the machine his boss David arrives
there David is an empathetic and
understanding man who is aware of
Peter's problems so he recommends him to
a good Clinic Peter disagrees that it's
all in his mind believing that what he
is seeing are actual prophetic visions
of an invasion that will soon come from
the sky however David warns him to
oblige or else he won't be allowed to
continue working at the office anymore
shortly after he again experiences some
strange Visions in one of them some
gunmen storm into a building and start
shooting everyone inside just then he
wakes up Disturbed and realizes that
he's been dreaming again at work to make
matters worse he's also late for the
family outing leaving his children
devastated hence fed up with what his
life has become he finally decides to
visit the clinic the next day he
announces to Alice that he has already
fixed an appointment with a doctor much
to her surprise and a joy at the clinic
Peter meets a fellow patient named Chris
who reveals that he is also having the
same Visions he then starts telling some
strange theories like someone wants to
control them by erasing their thoughts
these people are violent and deadly and
they are coming to Earth very soon Peter
is confused by the conversation but he
chooses to ignore it since the place is
filled with mental patience Peter is a
hypocrite after Chris goes in for his
appointment Peter has another strange
Vision this time he sees his boss David
and his family armed with guns and
walking around the city after Peter
snaps out of it he deduces that his
Visions are of an upcoming coming
Invasion which he does not want to be
erased hence he leaves the clinic
without treatment when he returns home
Alice asks him about his session and he
comes clean to her Peter thinks that he
is meant to see these things and that
something bad is about to befall them
fed up with all the BS Alice Cuts him
short and tells him to just get ready
for the party however at the party
strangely no one seems to be eating
anything as if they don't need it Peter
also continues to act strange and
constantly looks at the sky through the
telescope on the balcony when his
neighbor Ray comes over to talk a
strange luminous object falls from the
sky Peter thinks he is dreaming but Rey
confirms that those objects are in fact
real this attracts the attention of
Alice and Rey's wife Samantha so they
decide to join the men at the balcony
suddenly the flying object crashes into
a nearby building sending massive shock
waves that tear the city apart this also
causes Peter and the group to go flying
through the glass window and into their
apartment they quickly get up and have
another look through the balcony only to
find thousands of similar flying objects
descending on Earth from the sky above
terrified they rushed back into the home
Peter looks for his children and learns
that Hannah is at Rey's Place hanging
out with her daughter Maddie wasting no
time he rushes to find the girls with
Rey but just then an alien Soldier
appears and opens fire on them the men
narrowly escape and Run for Cover after
the soldier leaves they look for the
girls and eventually find them inside a
trapped elevator inside they also find
the dead body of a woman confirming that
whoever is flying those ships has
declared war on the city after rescuing
the girls they notice an armed Soldier
killing other residents mercilessly they
momentarily hide and at an opportune
time the two families part ways after
reaching his apartment Peter confronts
Alice and tells her that everything that
is happening right now he saw it in his
dreams but in a different order he
doesn't know what will happen next but
he feels that they should head for the
factory where he works the two then hear
the sound of more people getting gunned
down so they barricade the main door
before hiding the girls in their room
suddenly someone tries to force through
the main door prompting the terrified
couple to hold it from the other end
unfortunately amidst the chaos Lucy
walks out of the room to look for her
soft toy Herman and hides under a table
meanwhile after failing to gain entry
through the door the armed alien makes a
hole through the wall frightened Peter
and Alice run back to their daughters
only to realize that Lucy has ventured
out by then the arm daily and finds Lucy
and pauses to closely examine her taking
advantage of the slight distraction
Peter attacks the soldier from behind
Alice also arrives at the scene and
together the couple finally subdues the
alien following this Peter arms himself
with the Soldier's weapon and leads his
family to the roof there they reunite
with Rey and his family all of them are
shocked and devastated to witness their
once sprawling City covered in fire this
is what happens when your kids don't go
to school just then an Alien Drone
surveys the building with a flashlight
prompting them to quickly hide from it
then they realize that they cannot be at
the rooftop for long and decide to move
down with the help of the glass
cleaner's lift but unfortunately one of
the supports of the Crane's snaps
forcing them to enter An Empty Apartment
meanwhile it's revealed that the soldier
from earlier is still alive it is now
looking for the family tracking them
with a homing signal on the gun taken by
Peter on the other hand Peter examines
the alien's gun and realizes that it has
a biometric trigger which can only be
shot by its owner after hearing some
aliens approaching them he tells the
group to hurry to his Factory's basement
as it is the only safe place according
to his Visions but since the entire
region is surrounded by aliens he
doesn't know how to reach it luckily
Alice suggests that they can still reach
the basement through the tunnels that
she discovered during her work suddenly
an alien ship opens fire at them from
outside killing Rey and his family on
the spot Peter quickly escorts his
family out of the apartment but
encounters two armed aliens in the
hallway they quickly hide and Peter
desperately tries to bypass the rifle's
biometric authentication fortunately he
succeeds in the neck of time and kills
the soldiers Peter and his family then
make their way out of the building and
proceed towards the tunnel but right
before they can get in the alien ships
start firing at them injuring Alice in
the process Peter tends to his wife the
alien soldier from earlier catches up to
them and attacks him however Peter puts
up a fight and breaks the alien's helmet
to everyone's shock the soldier removes
his helmet and reveals that he is also a
human Peter demands answers but seeing
his wife bleeding out he threatens the
soldier with a gun and orders him to
carry Alice to the factory there Peter
and his family Unite with his boss David
and some other armed men the soldier is
apprehended and a doctor on the scene
tends to Alice his wounds to Peter's
shock the medic seemingly electrocutes
Alice as if she is Tech equipment David
then explains to Peter that The Invasion
has been expected for many years in fact
most of the people on Earth knew that
this day would come after further
examination on Alice the medic informs
Peter that she has received extensive
damage to her internal organs and hence
she cannot be saved just then the
soldier who is being dragged off for
execution shouts that he can save Alice
initially Peter assumes that he's simply
trying to wriggle his way out of the
situation but when he looks at his dying
he decides to give the soldier a chance
he also decides to stay with the soldier
and Alice letting David evacuate their
daughters to a subway station where a
transport train awaits them to take them
all to an off-site base before leaving
the daughters bid their parents an
emotional goodbye with no Assurance of
seeing them alive again shortly after
the soldier tears open Alice's wound and
Peter is shocked to see several wires
inside her body he panics and demands
answers to his surprise the soldier
reveals that Alice is an artificial
intelligence robot Peter is taken aback
by the Revelation and he becomes
speechless however the soldier tells him
that if he wants to save Alice he needs
an alternate source of power which is
Peter himself at The Soldier's guidance
Peter takes a pocket knife and warily
starts cutting open his own chest but
even though he makes a deep cut he feels
no pain at all after he is through with
the process he notices artificial organs
and wires inside his body confirming
that he is also synthetic as he tries to
get a grasp on the Revelation the
soldier brings out a cable and connects
it between two synthetics causing Peter
to pass out during this period he
experiences in detail about his
recurring nightmares it turns out what
he had thought were visions of the
future are actually memories of a past
War many years back the humans created
synthetic robots to serve them and
ultimately make the world a better place
to live in however the synthetics became
too smart and started a revolution
demanding equal rights as their human
counterparts they wanted to go to school
have emotions have a family and even
bear children like the humans however
their requests were immediately rejected
fearing an impending War the human
military attacked the unarmed synthetics
and killed a lot of them but the AI
synthetics fought back and using their
impeccable physical strength and
advanced brains they eventually drove
the humans off of the earth even Peter
himself killed one of them it is also
revealed that Peter and Alice met during
the tension one day while fighting
against the humans they came across
Hannah and Lucy who were grieving for
their deceased parents the girls are
synthetics but they were adopted by
human parents probably because they
couldn't have children of their own
seeing their pitiable condition Peter
and Alice calmed them down and decided
to adopt them at last to deal with the
guilt of how they killed humans most
synthetics including Peter and his
family wiped their memories of the war
and lived as humans unaware of their
nature or history however people like
David chose to keep their memory so that
they could prepare for the humans who
were hell-bent on taking Revenge we also
get to know that the clinic that Peter
went to earlier is one of the places
where the synths had their memories
suppressed and now that some synths are
getting fragments of their Memories Back
they're again being sent there back in
the present Peter and Dallas wake up and
the soldier miles explains that after
the humans fled from Earth on spaceships
they arrived on Mars and started
rebuilding for their ultimate Vengeance
during their time there the elders
taught the children that the synths are
terrible creatures who only know how to
kill and after 50 years of planning they
finally built Advanced Machinery and
weapons with the help of which they have
come back to reclaim what's supposedly
theirs however miles had always expected
this to be monsters not families with
children and after getting a good look
at Lucy under the table he decided that
he couldn't kill anyone after hearing
him out Peter has taken aback but
nonetheless he thanks miles for his help
before departing with his wife but as
they reached the tracks They are caught
between intense gunfire between the
synthetics and the humans fortunately
the synthetics Stands Strong allowing
Peter and Alice to escape from the place
and eventually reach the station where
the train is about to take off the
humans arrive even there but the
resilient David pegs them back with some
rounds allowing Peter Alice and himself
to get on the train after the train
takes off David reveals that he had to
keep his memory in order to prepare for
the upcoming War a decision which turned
out to be fruitful Peter Smiles at him
gently and hopes that someday there can
be peace between humans and synthetics
the movie ends as the train gets out of
the dilapidated City ensuring that the
synths on board can have ample time to
plan their next move subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help help the
channel out thank you for watching